oh
welcome thank you
such a pleasure it's my honor
intuition meditation
meditation intuition yes
lots to unpack it's a very important
show i'm grateful that shaker introduced
us
yes make this happen yeah
lyanna's got a lot of good images as
well
as we unpack
let's jump in
we'll start with the journey
so what was it like
growing up and how did you
become interested in what you care about
[Music]
today
i think just a natural feeling of
curiosity
and feeling that the picture
i used to see in my childhood is
something like you know there is
something else
there should be something else because i
was raised
in moscow and people around me had
pretty i would say
limited lifestyle pretty similar
you know everybody is going on a work
for five days
then two days they are drinking and
hanging out
you know like just just a similar
scenario
which was for me very boring
and i really wanted to see something
else
and i remember myself growing up and
thinking about traveling and just to be
connected
with different mindsets you know to see
how different people live and
yeah i was i was in a very strict you
know this like russian
environment i was playing violin for 11
years
my parents pushed me to do that i hated
doing this it was very strict discipline
and after school i went to university
which is my mom asked me to do i never
wanted to do that
i just wanted to go travel i wanted to
explore
and when i had a chance to get one-way
ticket to thailand
i was like um yeah
that's i think that's where my journey
starts
yeah all right
we'll get to this yeah we'll get to this
two years in thailand we'll get we'll
get here
initially what you were sharing it
very deeply resonated with me that
there is a a
culture of
stamping people out as
gingerbread cookies into the economic
machinery
to fill roles and so everybody
looks the same everybody
has their unique
contribution in a way but the process
of doing what you described
with a nine to five for five days and
then
for the two days undergoing some sort of
as many people hypothesize and it seems
to be correct that
when people undergo such processes
of intoxication the attempt is to
commune with god and
there are so many other ways of
investigating one's own consciousness
that lead to that feeling of communion
infinite consciousness
and we'll we'll get to some of these
spiritual
perennial wisdoms and so
it's it's funny that the way that the
economic machinery works is that
you have the
billions of people daily that
are veiling themselves from
the true nature of consciousness
by focusing on an external
objective pursuit
of money
and
materialism so
that seems to be a very common thing not
only as you described
in russia but in the united states
in the middle east in europe
in china and asia so it's becoming more
of
more of a common fetish of modernity
is rather than tuning inward
for what is
the role of my conscious what is the
role of reality
at large there is sort of a perpetual
veiling that occurs of consciousness in
some sort of nine to five
economic gears in a machine
so that was the first thing that really
resonated with me and i'm glad that you
even through your parental
pressure of 11 years playing violin
and even through your parental pressure
of going to university
even through that you still put the
pieces together
to get to thailand that's huge
because that one first foundational
moment is what opens up the doors
of perception of consciousness to higher
states of awareness to what is possible
outside of the machine
so good for you for doing that how did
you piece together the
finances to send yourself to thailand on
that one-way ticket
so i was working
on a place i was actually working as a
manager
yeah so very um
very machine mechanic work
you know and i collected some money
and i've met my future husband at the
time
who was already kind of out of the
system
you know and we just uh got high
one night i was smoking at the time
and i started to painting at that moment
i think i had my first artworks
and we were talking and that was this
moment of deep conversations when he
told me
like why you work in an office like look
at your
look at your artworks why are you
working in office
and i was honest and i just told him
because i'm scared
because i'm scared i need money
and he was like you you shouldn't do
that anymore
and this night i made this you need to
make this paper you know when you say
that
like i'm leaving so i collected the rest
of my money
uh he helped me with the with the part
for the tickets and yeah we just left
there
and we left with a few few of other
friends who basically as well
didn't really had planned we all were
you know
i was artist who's just starting to go
into this art and creativity and other
friends of mine
they already was on the creative path
and yeah we didn't have a plan we just
was like
you know we'll go and see what's going
to happen
and there was a moment when money
finished we didn't have money to go
back we were like eating rice
you know and picking coconuts
from bombs for a few months
yeah and
local people actually helped us a lot
they like they literally adopted us
for a few months and i got pregnant in
thailand
at this moment and my husband
he left to russia i mean he was lucky
enough he always
um he never betrayed himself in a way of
he always was a musician and he still
work as a musician now and sometimes
have really hard times you know but
he just like you know that's what i'm
doing that's what i'm great at
i'm not going to do you know delivery
work or something like that
and he left to russia because he was
already known out there and i stayed
in thailand because i didn't want to go
back in russia
and i plan to give birth of my child in
thailand first
and my mom she called me and she's in
traditional medicine
and she called me and said that i'm
worried about you you're alone pregnant
in a different country
please come back be a normal person
i will find a hospital for you and
i thought that again i did it for her i
came back in russia
and i think you know that's where i
would go
for intuition and connection to your
higher self and to
bigger let's say consciousness yes
uh i came back to russia it was
six months of my pregnancy
and i was in a traffic
in a taxi and
something happened where it was the
first time
where i didn't lose the sense of my body
and who i am i knew who i am i mean you
know like as lyanna
i'm in moscow okay and all these things
but at the same time there was a
like another sense which i can sense
through myself and which connects me
and everything around and this space
if i would say that this space was
talking with me that will be wrong
because you just like read the message
it's not a sound
it's not a picture but you know the
message and the message was
really clear you have to go and give
birth
of your child to india yeah
and i had no doubt that this is what i
have to do
at this same moment i googled
the offices which gives visas
you know yeah yeah and
i called there figure out what i should
do to get a ticket
and i called to my mom first and said
mom
i'm leaving in a two weeks to india
i never been there before and i remember
that was the first moment when she
really actually accepted me
i think like my craziness you know
yeah that's beautiful
i think that was for her like okay i
can't change her because all this time
she tried to because of yeah because of
she was sure she was she was scared you
know she was worried and that was
from her perspective um how she
let go yeah that moment she let go
and she was like you know what i support
you i support whatever
decision you're making i mean my husband
was freaking out for a little for a
little bit
because it was a close to new year time
uh so i gave
uh both to my baby in december
and because he's a musician he has most
of his
um work is on this celebration like new
year you know he has all this concert
and
he said i can't go with you and i said i
don't care i just i just go alone
yeah wow
how beautiful it is that
a your husband at the time still has
stayed true to his musical career
that's really interesting so you were
painting
at the same time that he was doing music
and that there was this
driving force within both of you to
escape away from that
machinery and go to thailand at the time
and you even brought friends
with you as well which is super
interesting so there's there's a good
amount of people that are
trying to figure out what is what exists
outside of that economic machinery
and then
it's also super interesting that the
classical example of a parent
who loves us who wants the best
for us that aims to expose us to
all these different fields and
opportunities and things like that
but in a sense struggles with that
last little bit of realizing
that my child came through
me into the world and my child is their
own
is their sovereign being to pursue
what they believe is their artistic
purpose their gifts
on the planet and so it's so unique that
i just i love how much of a moment
it sounds like it was for your mom who
as soon as you
came into this whatever that
space is where we
have these these feelings
of interconnection to
what can be said is all that is
some sort of field that we
are connected to where the message comes
in it's
clear you know and
that's profound it's as though there is
a higher
purpose for you
because you are no longer going to birth
your child
in the same process that you grew up in
in moscow and russia but instead it's
going to be
wildly different in a completely
different spiritual terrain
in india and so that single moment
was not only profound for you it was
profound for
your mom from your husband but also
profound for your daughter
really trajectory altering
intuitive lightning bolt that hit and i
think that's
a very fascinating
unpacking of that portion of of your
journey so
you ended up going just
following the flow
i wanted to add to uh what you just said
that
from my experience when you have this
deeper connection with yourself
and you know it can be something this
voice
from within you you know it can be
something really crazy
but i believe that every single being in
the universe
knows that this is truth and can
separate it
and when you following this truth
impulse
as you said people around you are
affected by this
light and truth as well they
can feel it sometimes they yeah
they can even rationalize it you know
yeah but they feel it and
you can see the reaction from them as
well
we'll explore the
the feeling of all eight billion people
knowing
that what you're describing and then
having that be a compass
of sorts in their trajectory and that
when they
follow along that then there is a
butterfly effect of
of people that are altered by those
trajectory paths
that are taken because that's very clear
on mine it's very clear on many of the
other guests that we've had
on the program is those
moments where the family
the friends
the community the social fabric
itself basically takes a
a big war
and that's when you break through
and it's like jumping through a portal
you know yeah that's what it is
that's what it is it's jumping through a
portal
it's a really important analogy
because every time that we jump through
one of those portals
what happens is our
consciousness evolves to higher
levels and there's no going back
and we bring other people with us
and if we don't go through the portal
the knock usually comes again at some
point
later
where along the
path of
the
calling to give birth to your child in
india
did it begin
the process of where
do i go in india how do i figure out
where to go
where to give birth how
do i surrender myself to that flow
yeah you know we was talking about that
earlier
that uh from my early childhood
i think that the one thing i've noticed
about myself
i had less fear than my surroundings
for the new experiences and one of the
most
and still the most scary thing for me is
an
ordinary boring life
[Laughter]
so for me it was just you know
i know that i will learn something
i know that it will be amazing i was
already
interested in hinduism you know i just
i knew that it will be it will be
interesting for sure it will be
interesting
you can guarantee that it will be really
interesting really novel shatter through
fear into new experiences that bring
lots of wisdom and insight so i didn't
have any plan
i didn't have a plan i have a trust
i have trust to my intuitive insight
and i just knew something about goa
i knew that this is friendly hippie
place you know
and i thought that people can give birth
to kids their
whatever they want under the tree
they're just like perfect
sounds like me and i went i went on a
plane and
i'm sitting like i'm on my seat right
and i see there is a pregnant girl
going like towards me and she looked at
me and she's like oh i know you
you're the you're andrea's wife
so because my husband at the time he was
pretty famous musician and she's like oh
i'm
like we're friends where are you going
do you know like where are you going and
i said no i never been
in india i guess i'll figure it out
there
and she said oh i'm flying there with my
mom and my brother and we have a place
to stay
my friend will let us stay and if you
want you can stay with us
and i said perfect
trust the process trust the process
and there's someone on the plane
that knows andreas
and that says we have a place for you
yes yes boom and i got there
uh i stayed with them at their friend's
place
during this time i was trying to find
the place where i can give birth to a
child
and as i told you i was sure that people
there are so open-minded you know it's
known
hippy place and i was sure you just can
literally give birth to your child at
home and that how i wanted
to do i didn't want to go to any
hospital you know being around random
people
i could feel that that at this moment
you have to be
specially connected with yourself and
with the flow
and nobody not no random
people has to affect you at this moment
you know it's
found exactly for your how old were you
at the time
21 you're 21 and you were recognizing
that
you needed to be in a space that was
conducive for the very very
profound divine spiritual process of
childbirth that's
very wise for 21 to know that
and i find it a place to stay
i paid for three months i think
you know in in advance for the rent and
right after i pay
and it was you know in india they uh
sometimes
the owners they will stay on the first
floor and they will give for rent the
second floor that's how
it was with me and the day after i gave
the money the owner of the house
came came up to me and um asked
where i'm going to give bills to a child
and i said
right here yeah in your second floor of
your house
yeah you're welcome by the way it'll
it'll make the energy of your house much
better trust me she didn't she didn't
agree
yeah yeah about about this thing so yeah
she said no way and she explained it and
it was so funny you know to see this
type of limitations because she said
oh we're brahmin family which is like a
highest
caste where bremen family and to give
birth to a child
it's um she explained to me that the
process is something dirty
and they can have it at home
and you know that was that was one of
the thing when i was
when i was thinking that the hinduism is
so enlightening deep and so enlightened
and
and how people can limit
limited you know and being a brahmins
and make rituals
every day yes yes and still
use this type of perception yes yes
anyways i was okay with that i said
okay i'll try to look for another place
and just
accept it and try to go around and i'm
finding another place
absolutely new house the first question
i ask to owner is can i give bills to a
child
that's the first question now yeah he
said okay
yeah you you can you can do that so i'm
finding a place
and packing my stuff so i remember i
pack my last
box you know and i feel that
it started yeah
at this like old place you know where i
can't give birth to a child yeah
at the old place and i call
to to the girl i know i knew her from
thailand we've met in the thailand and i
knew that she was in goa
uh and i called her and i said hey i
think i'm
i'm giving birth right now can you can
you come and she
she came to my place at night wow
um yes and she brought another woman
who is not traditional i don't know how
how would you call the woman who give
who
help to give birth yeah the delivery
nurse or yeah not not the traditional
one she was
more suggesting the ways
the posture you can do how you can
breathe
she was all alternative yeah
practitioner
exactly she was giving you posture and
breath she
yeah i did i didn't use it though i
didn't i didn't use it though
so i think that's um interesting also
very important experience about
this you know choose between love and
fear and just you know
being able to go through fear yes
that's what you said you know is
important an example of me flying to
thailand yes
and i remember when it starts when the
process starts
and that's the moment where you really
feel
you can't control it this is a process
which happening through you
yeah and there is two choices other
you either let it happen through you and
stay totally open yeah or either you try
to fit it in your boxes yeah
and that's where the wrong
how to say that's where suffering starts
starts let's say
you know wow and i remember it um
on just my sensations in my body
where i said to myself i'm letting this
flow
go through me and
i don't remember myself i was this
protest and yes
that's right that's right yeah
and she was this woman she was
suggesting me she was like oh
do you want me to make a massage for you
or do you want to try this
and i was like no i know what to do i
just know what to do
and i did super weird posters
super weird sounds you know yeah
and i just knew what to do and i'm so
happy that
i wasn't brainwashed at the moment
because before as i said i was in
thailand
and most of the times uh i when i came
back in russia i was there for maybe a
couple weeks and before there i just
stayed alone
in thailand in jungles playing
didgeridoo
singing you know nobody is around who
will tell me
you know you have to read this book and
to learn how to breathe right
man there are so many women did it
before me i know that
if i'm connected with myself you know
yeah and
that's that's was one of the most
amazing experience
that was very painful
but at the same time that was divine you
know
yes
[Music]
i think it's so interesting how you took
the the reigns of sort of
being in a state of such flow where
you just trust the process and
that you will move strangely
or s make strange noise and you will go
through something that is extremely
painful and divine and you
birth your daughter into the world yes
yes this is this is a very important
experience in people's lives very very
very important
so so what now
you know do you feel relief you feel
divine connection
to your child walk us through that hmm
yeah i'm trying to figure out how to
explain the sacred moment which just
happened between us
and the kitchen you know because um
there was in this house i stayed
everything was amazing but there was one
thing there was a dog
which the owners didn't feed by the
purpose
because they kept some type of medicine
in their house and they were scared that
somebody will rob them right and they
wouldn't feed a dog
so she was very very nervous all the
time you know how
uh if you don't feed animal it becomes
very nervous and would react on
every sound every little movement so
the only thing which was distracting me
uh is was this dog she was barking all
the time
and usually india is full of beautiful
sounds of a bird
birds you know cows would come
and you know monkeys and there was
none none of it around our house because
of this duck
and i was really um i was nervous that
when i will give birth baby she will
wake uh wake her up and
at the night when i gave birth to maya
this dog i still don't know how
but she ran away she was on a huge
metallic chain
and she never came back
somehow broke a metallic chain i i have
no idea how it's happened but the thing
is at the moment when i gave birth to
maya
the first thing i've heard there was a
two cows
which came to our house and i was like
wow it's so
um unfamiliar sounds out here
and the birds were flying and the
monkeys was jumping
all around yeah and then we figured that
the dog has run away that's why
that's why it happened yeah and i wonder
what the
energetic trigger is for your
process of childbirth and the dog
breaking away from his chain and and
vacating the premises so that there is
space
for the birth and the the cows and the
birds and the more natural
sort of process of a less stressed
creature
in that sense and maybe the dog actually
to survive needed to break away
in order to get food yeah yeah
so again one of those extremely sacred
divine moments where that happened
and it was just the perfect
birthing scenario then it became and so
so was that then
relief and divinity holding maya what
was that like
hmm i think the
most interesting experience for me at
the moment was
to feel
that there is different soul
different character different person
because when she was inside of me
i felt like i'm the one and when i seen
her first time
and i told you the story about names i
had the names in my my god
i want to give her and like yeah it
became
two yeah and that was absolutely
incredible and switched my perception in
the whole world
because i started the first the time
started to flow differently i started
to feel life in a different way
you know just how the plants are growing
how one produce another
you know all the cycles of life i didn't
really pay attention to that before
yes and when she was born it's just
happened with me you know i was just for
a year
i think i kind of was living in a
psychedelic trip where i literally
could feel this living space
around me how everything is alive you
know that's right
that's right
wow
[Laughter]
wow
that's quite a profound way to describe
the process of
being a a pregnant mother
and having the
child inside that is
of one with you and then as
the child is birthed into the world it's
becomes so evident that it is now
two it is now its own
unique soul and
yeah yeah wow
and it's no surprise at all that that
tapped you into
a straight
you can say trance you were
in a year long
like you described psychedelic
experience and
that's a higher level of consciousness
is one that
truly is that tapped into its
environment at such a level where it is
really connecting to even the growth
of the the plants the growth
of the
the life of the animals just that style
of
experience tapped in at that higher
degree being
you know triggered by that divine
childbirth is
it's super important it's really
awakening
it's really describes the
interconnection i'm
i'm quite obsessed on the program
with sharing with people that
they take 20 000
inhales
every single day and that
every one of those inhales comes from
the photosynthesis of phytoplankton and
trees
and to truly realize that style
of cyclical interconnectedness
on the planet is profoundly
life-changing
but we brush over it like it's nothing
how interested in this that actually
just
few questions can take you
to the nature of mind to compassion
and love and how everything is connected
you know just from thinking how this
food
yes got to your plate what was before
right just just few steps yes
what you just described is a process
that
if consciousness is truly
truly dedicated to truth truly dedicated
to awakening
truly dedicated to enlightenment
it will undergo this dedicated process
that you speak of where it inquires into
the truth of its own existence at that
level
and it really requires sometimes it
requires
just some simple inquiries about
these breaths of air these bites of food
it's just the simple inquiries
and they lead
to states that
are so profoundly shifting
that everything that you do
after that is gold
everything so that means that you
act from a state of such
high morals ethics
and acting from that state
butterfly affects more and more
consciousness to in go undergo the
process
of investigating its own nature
and reality you act as a
channel for
the butterfly effect
of more and more consciousness
to inquire about its own self and its
own nature
so i love this i love how
much we're unpacking this in its
surgical
nuance it's beautiful it's like a flower
i've i love that analogy it's like every
guest on the show is their own unique
flower essence and you're taking us down
an incredible journey so let's
let's go into that that year with that
first year with
maya and connecting to
this what you describe as a psychedelic
first year of
pro post child birth you know that was
interesting that's the thing i want to
talk about
uh talking about this year
i think i was also in a type of
sphere like energetic sphere of
my child of her
you know still super extremely
open cosmic consciousness you know
and i was i literally could feel it as
you know as like a field around me
around her
and i was not really
uh got into connection with other people
i felt like i was more protecting her
and but i was able
to observe what's happening around me
and i feel that it's such a blessing
that i came
to india to give her birth because
you know there are so many different
esoterical
and spiritual people around who was
i don't know trying to raise their
kundalini
you know and just like do different
practices and the first year actually i
was
with my child totally connected with her
in this how i would say cocon
cocoon exactly and i was observing
how many people are going crazy
you know and i've just seen so
many people
who i think claiming to be spiritual
from a wrong motivation
and especially in goa in india it's
pretty easy life you know many
most of the people they let's say
rent their place in russia which their
own
and they just like leave very easily
and i just seen that
many people were really unbalanced like
you know as
i was talking about you that at some
point i would have very different
and opposite environment where there
will be materialistic businessmans
who believe only in material world and
all these hippies you know and as i said
i'm really
i'm really happy that i got there to
give birth to my child so i wasn't able
to put myself to go through all this
experience but i was just noticing that
they missing something you know they
doing all these practices but they can't
deal
with normal life you know
the anchoring of the conscious ascent
that is attained
in the modern social fabric
that is a
critical perennial spiritual wisdom
is to anchor these ascents and
consciousness
in the center of the social fabric of
the metro
and i feel like you know the any
spiritual practice is a first about
discipline
you know and as you said
you know i just made a commitment with
myself to do
the podcast every day and i'm doing it
700
days i have seven 700 podcasts and
you know if you truly developed your
spiritual practice
you will be able to
figure things out here you know
yeah i want to say that you gave this
part of what you were saying that was
again so
insightful you talk about this
there's two things here one of them is
that
you have this sort of
cocoon that you described for you and
maya
and in that
cocoon you have
these experiences
that to me what my
interpretation of it is is something
like
a mother being extremely
aware of their child's
inputs of what their child is taking in
and so what
there's a huge transition from their
child
taking in what we were talking about
is available in the economic machinery
of
a place like moscow or maybe new york or
whatever
completely different in terms especially
of the amount
of people in the economic machine versus
as you use the word hippie or people
pursuing maybe a spiritual path
or something in like manhattan
you're like really skewed scales
super skewed and in india it may be a
little bit more
balanced there may be a lot
more people pursuing some sort of
spiritual path
and a lot less people that
are doing uh economic machinery
materialism
solely focused practice
right what i'm trying to say is
um especially
in this state where you have just a
newborn child
you can feel the truth with your
body and you can feel the intentions of
people
and there is an intention of spiritual
development which goes through fear yes
and there is cover of like oh
i'm spiritually developing but
actually you're just lazy you know what
i mean
interesting okay and going into
also you know it's like a lot of yes yes
okay let me yeah let me hit this back
because this is a very important point
if i understood correctly
so one of the
important realizations of
what is
modern people is to do things
like realize that materialism is not
only it
there is a spiritual path that is
interesting where i investigate my
consciousness and the nature of reality
and so there's that and then for the
spiritual people on the very spiritual
path
is to
rather than what may be sometimes what
is called a spiritual bypassing
where there is some sort of a
process of i am on the spiritual path
and there's actually no
work that's being done it's more of us
saying something about it
or there's even if they do undergo the
process of being on the spiritual path
there is no
intention to anchor any of the things
that are learned
in the world in the way of actually
helping people and helping the world
and so there's both sides that have
there
in a sense you could say perverse
incentives or their dirty bath water
and then there's this beautiful baby in
both of them as we say in
chapter 7 of the sorting algorithm and
high level perception where you take the
baby out of
the bath water of the physicalists
and you take the baby out of the
bathwater of the spiritualists and you
bring them together into one
and then you have a truly divine reality
yes yes i love that yes yes
yeah and there's a lot of dirty bath
water in both of them as well
so there's examples quick
where you have the
i've used this example before it's very
sensitive
example is that we have a
planetary
truly an emergency but
very much so brushed off like it is not
where the economic machinery is creating
such intense pressures on countries like
brazil in the congo to
go ahead and destroy their rainforests
and their biodiversity and those
trees that sequester 30 of the carbon
that is in the atmosphere
and contribute to 30 percent of the o2
that we inhale
and those perverse incentives
of the economic machinery are making it
so that
people think in short-term gratification
of
taking themselves further out of the
poverty
because they want more of the physical
benefits
of meeting those basic needs and things
like that
but that we should have the foresight we
should
think like the seventh generation
indigenous
principle that
very clearly knows that it is a
bad idea to
mortgage our future for the short
term gains of this moment of chopping
down those
rainforests so
and the the true
sort of one that
knows is one that knows the synthesis of
science and spirituality because they
can actually speak about
the forests from a perspective that is
grounded
both in spiritual insight of being in
awe at the divine of the rainforest and
the biodiversity
and the love that is there but it's also
grounded in the science where they can
actually explain
on a scientific level about the
photosynthesis
and the oxygen we inhale and they can
explain on an
on a biodiversity level regarding what
the beautiful things are that we can
actually
leverage from the creatures that are in
those environments and gain them as
biological insights in the way we try
and augment
ourselves and also they understand from
an
economic perspective how to shift
markets away from short-term consumption
and towards the
7th generation indigenous principle this
is the kind of stuff
that i preach on the program
so i love that uh
you know that's interesting because i
gave this explanation of the tree for
kids for younger kids to teach them
meditation
so they imagine themselves as a at the
tree
right with the root going down and with
the top
trying to touch the sky you know and
feeling the core
within them it's beautiful yeah
oh and you know i have to tell about
india i kind of started very you know
from the
from the top from my top experience yes
um for sure india is the heart opening
place
you know but there is uh
also like we started to talk about
psychedelics a little bit and
from what i said about people who was
like
going crazy a little bit and where i
found this disbalance
i have this really beautiful um
quote from one russian musician
he said that only person
who have a higher education can take up
psychedelics that means that if you have
an
inner structure if you can structure
this experience
you know you can go there
but if you don't have a right motivation
if you don't have
structure you can just lose yourself
let's say sure and i think yeah
that's where i started to learn also
about buddhism because i
loved the structure of buddhism
yep you know and i think
um
i would say that how you said about
transformation
and seeing how how we develop like on a
two opposite sides yeah right
yep that the same thing about
transformation like which i which i
found
in goa i've seen at first not really
pleasant things which took me to
buddhist teachings and not to really go
into experience but been able to explain
and to learn
how it works you know
it was really nice when you were
beginning to describe the ways that
you teach meditation mindfulness
to children
i look forward to being able to unpack
that
yes so many things yeah i'm trying i'm
trying to think where
where i should go remembering our plan
you know
yeah well maybe the
continued
space where you unpack for us
both your interest in the
buddhism that was occurring around you
but
also the continued process of raising
your daughter
kind of happening simultaneously
figuring out what was happening there
okay you made this connection between my
daughter and
learning buddhism and i just remembered
this
very interesting insight and it goes to
understanding the nature of mind which i
want to
bring up i think about the first uh
vipassana experience
that was the first time when i was able
to my daughter she was three years old
and i was able to leave her
with my mom in russia so we spent
um we spent the season in goa and then i
i came back in russia and i was already
introduced in tibetan buddhism but i
really
and there is a different traditions in
buddhism and like according to buddhist
philosophy
you should rather pick one path and
follow it than try
many but i'm different type of person
just for a moment to be on that point
because it's a very
important point there's a balance
that is struck between what is called
and this is what dustin de perna taught
me a very
incredible spiritual teacher that
be careful chasing two rabbits
because you won't catch either oh wow
yes and then there's another one
that goes when you dig
all the way
make sure you hit water and so
be careful with digging stopping
digging stomping digging stomping
digging stopping dig all the way until
you
hit water and so
it's a balance i would say because of
the sampling
is what
also enables profound
connections and that those connections
are what lead people to
the
perennial spiritual philosophies and
wisdoms
and so it makes it a lot more
easy to
co-exist harmoniously as a planet
once we've made these perennial
spiritual connections
and if we're digging just to one water
and we think i have the gold my gold is
best
i know truth and we haven't
sampled this is where problem can
occur so it's balance that's my
small two cents on that yes yes
i like that um
i asked my tibetan teacher
if i can go to the pasana because
vipassana is different tradition from
tibetan buddhism it was gayanka's
vipassana
and start again
[Laughter]
i love him i love him i love him
great story yeah and my teacher said
yes it will help you with your practice
and i left my daughter uh with my mom
so your tibetan teacher said that yes
yes will help you with your practice
that's a very important insight that you
just shared with us because sometimes
the teachers of different spiritual
traditions
will in a sense uh
they will [ __ ] on other
spiritual traditions and so it's
actually really nice that
that that was your experience because
i've had that and i've also had
other experiences where spiritual
teachers have a shot on other
traditions and so which is very
interesting because then you wonder like
so much of your teaching is so beautiful
but why do you take a
[ __ ] on someone else's spiritual
tradition so anyway
okay i think it's one of the criteria at
least it was
for me because i always wanted to learn
something
about ordinary human experience which is
separate and find dualities and
everything and my teacher pressures
guardian rimpacha
i'll talk about it also
uh he is just a pure compassion pure
love
and the always what he's saying he said
when you take refuge which is a
traditional
ritual in buddhism he said it doesn't
mean
that you can't go to church that you
can't
uh that you can try different traditions
that means that there is a core
principle is love and compassion
until you see it everywhere till you
find
one in a different you're on the right
path
you know yes so you gave
maya to your mother so that enabled you
to go
to the vipassana through the vipassana
which is 10 days
practice no talking silent
no speaking no eye contact without my
contact
yeah no no technology no distractions
no distractions multiple
hours per day of practice from the
sitting in the meditation hall nine i
think
yeah from sitting in the meditation hall
all the way to
being alone in uh individual cell
dark cell alone and
please yes um
i get there and
they took when you go to the person in
india i don't know if
they do it around the world but in india
they're pretty strict so they take away
your
phone to make sure that you're not they
take away your phone
your ids basically all everything what
you have
you just yeah yeah you just go there
strict here and
i remember i'm in the line to give away
my stuff
and i see the text like the the last
thing i've seen before
to go to vipassana was a text from my
mom
and she was asking me to send her my
signature
for the surgery or for my daughter
because she had some problem
with her teeth so they had to make her
fall asleep
to make the surgery so i had to send the
signage
to my signature to let them do that
so can you imagine you go to retreat
you know you go to meditate and this is
a very last thing you see
and i'm sending this signature and
i think there is a fourth day of
vipassana
and the biggest struggle of the practice
is
uh pain in your body because you're
sitting all the time
and even i was already practicing yoga
and my body is
pretty healthy uh i had
very bad back pain and just you know
my left side would go numb all the time
and from the third day on the pasana
practice
it starts um the committed
i think one and half hour practice where
you make a commitment for 90 minutes
not move at all because like the
movement is something what
helps you you know not suffer a lot when
you move in a little bit strange during
the practice and here
your make this commitment and do this
practice few times in a day
and i remember i said to myself
okay i'm going to do that i'm going to
do that
and i was sitting this hour
and the pain was so bad i could feel
that
i would start i thought that i will fall
you know just will
lose my mind and will total its turn
north and fall
and i think at the moment of highest
point of pain my mind
and i just started to think about maya
like how is my daughter what's going on
with her right now what's going on with
surgery
and at this moment i figured when my
mind was there
i didn't feel pain
and it's just like in a second was
transformed
to a bliss and i was able to see it with
no
movement by the end of the retreat that
was one of the
experience of the mind you know how
our mind creates the reality how our
mind
cling to the pain or to the pleasure
and you know all of a sudden like it
goes somewhere else
and this not exists anymore
yeah that's a very important insight
we
from a neuroscientific perspective we
talk about this as
excessive rumination in the default mode
network so
it's a excessive compulsive
rewind and replay over and over again
of the same
loops activating the same neural
circuitry
and what you're doing is you're causing
yourself a tremendous amount of
suffering
and so in this case with vipassana what
happens is
you have a it's a it's a big deal you
have to sit
in meditation for 60 straight minutes
that's
mine was 60. and
this is no movement you can't move and
so if you're
trying to adjust your legs or if you
feel pain in your back or
the pain is the number one excuse that
the consciousness goes towards
it's the number one excuse the monkey
mind is usually
you know most people figure out how to
quiet the monkey mind at least enough to
where the pain becomes the number one
thing
so people figure out that within
three seconds of observing my
respiration my mind has wandered off to
my job my work my
family my friends
the musical songs that i like my
childhood my
interest in my romantic partner my
any story runs to that story and it
stays in that story and it's insane that
it stays in that story for 30 or 60
seconds
before you realize
that wasn't i just observing my
respiration
and so that's the first moment for
people usually
of waking up because they realize
how insanely programmed they are
in their inability to even focus on
their respiration
for more than three seconds before that
monkey mind
runs away and is excessively ruminating
in some stories
and so that's usually the like okay so
now i'm gonna
i'm gonna focus on my respiration for
five seconds
and then it turns to 10 seconds and 20
seconds and 30 seconds and then a minute
and finally you hit a minute of being
able to
hold on to your own focused spotlight of
conscious
awareness and attention on your
respiration
and then imagine trying to bring that up
to 60 minutes
so then usually the top thing that comes
is that
um my back my knees my
etc and so
it's a very important realization that
you had that
when the awareness goes
to focus in on some sort of lower back
pain or knee pain
that even something like the trigger of
thinking about
maya as she enters into her surgery for
her tooth
is something that can distract away from
the pain
and then realize that there was just a
an aversion to the actual pain that was
occurring like you're suffering about
suffering you not
actually experience pain yeah
there you go there you go that's a
really profound realization
excellent okay so that's you said that
was only
like the first kind of big one did you
yeah on the
okay and this was was this day four you
said i think it was day four
when this uh commitment meditation
starts on the third on the fourth
day something like that yeah yeah and
that's interesting because um
before the vipassana i got to meet dalai
lama
and that was my uh first big teachings
and he gave the teachings to monks
in dram salah in his residency and there
is a
different type of teachings he will give
to um
you know to western students and to
monks
and i was able to go to this teachings
and
he explained this traditional tibetan
meditation of avalokiteshvara where
you i was
i was thinking he's it's like is it a
joke
because you have to imagine at the same
time so
many things he wouldn't continue to add
things
he would say okay you on the top of your
head
there is buddha virachana uh move from
the left to the right
around it there is a mantra goes in one
direction there is another one
in a different direction and around you
there is few mantras
and normal tibetan monks they keep in it
in their mind and they are
able to do that yes
that's about you know what's happening
after you're able to
keep your focus for one hour that's
right
yeah then you get thrown into some
advanced dalai lama
practices wow and so that that's really
interesting
did you have a picture of that
experience too
i think you said did you i have uh i
have a picture
of my refuge with my guardian rinpoche
uh no this is another input no go down
no not this one another
okay cool so we'll show this one to you
guys
yeah this is a refuge that's
very interesting
and important moment of my life
and i think we can go here to
transformation
can i start to talk about that yes
coming up right
now all right so so which
one more time which rinpoche
was important this is garcia rip yeah
this is on a picture this is garcian
rinpoche this is my core
precious teacher i started to talk about
him
a little bit in the way of uh he's a
pure compassion you have
another picture of him if you can um
um on up yeah
this one and the next one yeah that's
it is actually in arizona right before
the corona hits because he has a center
in
arizona oh cool yeah okay
and that's is that by chance with some
of the
leaders that are studying consciousness
at in arizona is he does he collaborate
with
that i'm i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure
he does i don't know
i don't know exactly but he's very open
you know if somebody would ask him to do
that so
interesting might be because we have
some friends in arizona that
are at the edge of consciousness and
they work
with practitioners from the east and
it would be interesting if he's not
already doing that to potentially
link them up so that's something for us
to explore
okay so so
this is you about a year ago
or so uh this is yes about a little more
than
okay more than more than a year ago and
i just wanted to go through
you train your mind to focus
and then you train your mind to be able
to stay focused on love and compassion
and my first meeting with rimpache
was actually in russia he gave
again that was one of these magical
moments
and it connected with my mom too that's
very interesting
um i had this little little necklace
of little buddha which fell off and i
couldn't find it
and i really i really really loved it
and i remember i was at my
mom place in russia and i was going uh
through the facebook and i've seen the
event
that rinpoche is coming and at this
moment
my mom she came to me and she's like oh
i found your
buddha and she gave it to me and this is
you know this
moment of yeah and you found the event
at the same time that your mom found the
booty necklace yeah
those are so beautiful it's art i love
it and sure it's like with the tickets
to india
i was thinking i have to go there and
as i said at this moment i was staying
for a few days at my parents house and
my childhood was pretty tough i
wasn't growing up with my dad i don't
know my dad but
i had my stepdad who was drinking all my
childhood and
you know acting on the drunk
on the drunk behavior can i say that
right yes and
it was very painful and i remember
already
being on a spiritual path and
intuitively and rationally
understand the importance of developing
love
and connection to everyone i let
myself hate my stepdad because
i was thinking that he deserve it and i
don't even want
to work through that with him
i will just i just let myself
you know hate him that's that's it and
at this moment i stay at my parents
house
and still have this complicated
relationships with my
uh with my dad i was visiting moscow and
i had to
you know i had to stay with them and i'm
going to
i was going to syrian pacha and you know
he gave this
open lecture where he said very simple
things
very very simple things about you know
that you should be more loving more
compassionate
and i was kind of a little bored on this
lecture
and i was thinking that oh okay i've
heard i've heard it so many times if
he's going to give some special
techniques you know the school tibetan
llama
and he didn't said anything and then all
of a sudden
uh he's like oh i'm actually i'm going
to give a refuge and refuge
is um um traditional ritual in tibetan
buddhism where you take
refuge in a buddha dharma and sankha
which the core thing means that you are
not
seeking any more happiness
externally you only rely on your inner
buddha so you take in refuge in a buddha
which is your own mind in a dharma
the path the meditation path and you
believe that there is a way
which will take you to the state of mind
and the sankha
is a community of like-minded people for
the moments when you're sometimes
getting lost
and starting to think oh this person i
don't know this person this hurt me or
he's not cool they will help you to
bring your focus within you
and he gave the refuge uh technically
it's
they cut a little piece of your hair
interesting
yeah yeah i was wondering after i
started to ask people about what is
going what's happening with the hair
after because he's collecting it
all in a little back and they said that
they send it to tibetan monastery
and mnemonics is praying for a few
months
i think from for a few months or a few
weeks i don't remember
exactly on this hair and sending and
sending
intentions you know sending a good
intentions wow
yeah and so i was there uh with my
friends who was already
uh practicing tibetan buddhism and
i could i really trust them and i tried
to
ask them before or what does that mean
the refuge and they explained to me
briefly and they just said
this is a great llama you should go and
do it you won't regret it
yeah i was like okay and i did this uh
refutral
next day i'm coming back to my parents
place
and uh when i was a child that was a
similar same situation which was
happened over and over
my stepdad he would get drunk and he
would
he would sit somewhere where i am you
know and he would sit like that
and looking at me and waiting for a
moment to start drama
you know and then yeah
that's right yeah i'm aware of this
archetype
i'm yeah
and you know the same situation i
remember i remember it so clearly
i'm staying in the kitchen cooking rice
and he's sitting in the kitchen drunk
looking at me really angry trying to
find this moment where he
can start argument and all of a sudden
i'm finding myself again
at this space where i still i know who i
am
i see my emotions i see his emotions
but through this through me through him
through everything there is
another consciousness
which is a love and compassion and which
go through
all the [ __ ] that's right and it's
just like everywhere
perfect and i'm at this state and i'm
ever aware
of the situation and i don't know for
how long it was
but there was so many insights there the
first thing
is i knew that everything what happened
between us
and that he
hurt me all my during all my childhood
that's supposed to happen this way yes
i just had this feeling you know of like
explanation
there is a lot of explanation of karma
but you have this experience it's you
know
very very different and i just felt so
much love and the only thing i wanted to
say sorry
and can you imagine it's all happening
like in my head basically
in my mind and for a few seconds and i
turn my head
on him and he's standing up
coming to me start to hug me that's
right start to cry
that's right and say i'm sorry i love
you
i'm sorry i love you and we both cry
and my mom passing by is like what the
[ __ ]
no i don't care you know
and the thing is i ended some very
serious trauma
and misery and suffering in your lineage
and in his that that whole sphere you
ended that
we end it when we do the work that you
did
i knew that it's connected with rinpoche
i knew that uh there was a connection
with me
meeting erin poche i clearly knew
that yes connection with his
consciousness
with his loving compassion consciousness
made me able to see this space
you know this unlimited space of love
and compassion
and i was like man i wanna i wanna learn
it like i wanna know
how like how does it work and i found
the guys
who uh organized uh
his visit and i found their center in
moscow
and i came to the practice and tibetan
buddhist practices are
very weird weird because they are all
about you know
uh working with non-dual state of mind
and you will take the most disgusting
things
and meditate on them put your focus and
see
this compassion and love basically learn
how to see through the [ __ ]
you know and i i didn't understood
anything and that was so difficult they
have all this mudras
and rituals and i was just okay i just
you know i trust what happened with me
i'll just do that because
then i will figure out and you know to
put it simply
and what is my values right now is
to help people really
understand that you are able to learn
how to be loving how to be compassionate
this is a skill
and this is something what can go
through the [ __ ] and
heal the biggest traumas yes which
you think you already claim like okay
it's here
you know i like it was for me i hate him
and i'm fine with it
you know
as you were telling it
i knew that there was going to be
something profoundly awakening
that you are going to be sharing about
it because you're right that the contact
with the
highest
consciousness that is trained in the
planetary mystic traditions
will in fact butterfly affect
tremendous wisdom onto
the other which is then
carried with them wherever they go
and then they begin seeing at a higher
level
of perception everything around them to
the degree that you were describing your
experience with your stepfather
being something where vast majority 90
plus
percent of people fall into the same
trap over and over and over
again but that you saw through that to
the infinite love and compassion
and i should add that he quit drinking
right away oh we never had an argument
again you know that's that's not just
you know oh that was
this wasn't just a hug yeah that was
just a hug and everything is good
drinking yes and never had another
argument with you
that's that's it that's it
right there right there that's it so
it's a little bit
there are many people that choose to
continue
arguing with me when i tell them
that please stop
being hubristic you are overly
self-confident
you do not have enough humility because
you are 20
30 40 50 years old
and you continue insisting that the
planetary
spiritual mystic traditions
that are thousands of years old have no
wisdom to teach you
and you keep doing it over and over
again
this is a perfect example of the wisdom
that the planetary mystic traditions
have
it's a perfect surgical example
one of the enlightened sages pass along
a tremendous amount of wisdom which then
cascades an insane butterfly effect
in a family that ends trauma
and that ends suffering and that
butterfly effects have more happiness
more peace more joy more bliss
more truth and
that in itself is plenty
of evidence along with all of the
other scenarios that are just like this
yummy one that you share for people
to become less
hubristic more humble
in acknowledging the fact that there is
something very
very valid and very important and very
perennial about the planetary spiritual
mystic traditions you know i think
there's
it's uh you know as buddha said you
don't have to take it as a belief
i think just to be able
to feel the space and to be
in the presence of certain people and to
see
how your mind changes how your even the
flow of your thoughts changing is
important yes
you just can you just can try and feel
it you know and
i experienced it so many times and i was
blessed
with my teachers where you
truly can feel how you change and and
tibetan buddhism there is
um this understanding of uh transmission
they say that you can there is a
technique for a practice
but there is also the transmission where
you can
feel the essence of practice from the
teacher
and that's why these lineages exist
where from teacher to student from heart
to heart
you're receiving the truth and not
losing anything not adding anything but
just
clearly continuing the flow that's right
very eloquently said
and then as that goes
down the lineage
we ourselves become stewards
of the
eradication of suffering and the
bliss joy
peace compassion
and true nature of consciousness and
reality that we then
go on to
lovingly pass along more and more with
everything that we do
and everything that we touch every
person that we engage with
so it's gorgeous it's
i love it i love it we
went through some of the stories
so far are there other ones that you
think
from this portion of your experience
that you think are
important to to share you maybe it would
be nice to maybe
reference how you've been doing with
maya at this
time right because you're becoming
i mean all the way up to to this
up to this picture here you're
my maya's like pretty much eight or so
years old or something
and so that's kind of a big chunk of
time so like how was that i guess
process also with
raising maya along the way i'm blessed
with my child
i'm truly i'm truly blessed with my
child
and from how i was raised
and you know i had all this
ideas which sounds sounded really crazy
to my mom
and you know my my mom and my
grandfather my grandmother mother who
was raised me they was
very structure minded and
they expressed they love and care to me
by keeping me grounded
and whatever i would say oh i want to go
travel
you know i want to do that my mom would
say no
you have to go to college you have to
learn how to
i remember this phrase you used to tell
me when i was a kid you have to learn
how to play violin
and at least you will always have some
money for
food like you can play she would say
you can play in the underground you know
and you can have some money whatever
happened with you
your hands are here and you know just
like this
thinking from fear and
trying to keep me on a certain structure
which they thought was safe for me
which will keep me safe and
which was so like a prison for me
you know emotionally and energetically
and i think that's why
i chose to raise my child
absolutely opposite way
and it's not easy sometimes you know
because
um i showed you she's a skateboarder
she loves to skate yeah you can you can
show her instagram probably with a video
yeah we will trust me i love these
so much all right so
and so we're on all right we're on
this is this is lyanna's instagram you
can find
the link in the bio below so go and
visit it
it's really on point and she has the
link to
maya's instagram right there at the top
in the bio
and then we'll click through that
and then here's maya's
where it says don't hate go skate in the
bio so that should be enough
for you to yeah i love
i love this this this is such a good
picture of yeah it's such a strong one
such a good one yeah i have another gray
hair when i go to skate park with her
that was a really interesting story uh
when she first
time came to united states and she has
the story in her
one of her posts i think you've read
when we were going through her instagram
uh we were passing by uh homeless people
on the skateboards and maya never seen a
skateboard before and she asked me hey
mom what is what is this thing
and i said this is skateboard and she
asked if i can get her one
so straight from airport we went to
venice beach and i got her penny board
this is kind of kids colorful board you
can't go
uh that she paint on some stranger
t-shirt
her logo
it's a good story it's uh yeah it's
right here on the
mm-hmm yeah
yeah what's up and she and she started
to she started to skate
and she was falling she was bleeding
she was bleeding from all over the
places
every day and getting back to skate park
so
even local guys you know local
skateboarders who are sometimes
annoyed by uh kids in the skate park who
is very slow and just take
place you know take space and not really
skate i think they started to respect
her
and they would start to show her tricks
you know and she got sponsored i think
after uh
after the first year of skating i guess
uh by amber chromebandfitch
yeah that's here yeah
and with maya you know i just
truly believe that
kids still have access to
the bigger picture and
higher consciousness till the moment
when society and family will
put their lab labels and limitations
so i tried to raise her
through just giving her space
to notice things
to explore things and to
to make her own mind about things you
know yeah
i'm not trying to tell her what is good
and
what is bad but i'm more trying to ask
what does she thinks and you know that's
very interesting because
she has very
strong sense of
what's right and what's wrong she has
very strong
sense of a truth yes and she
really can recognize it i i remember
that was one of my friend
he told me this phrase which i still
remember he said
you know how to recognize truth
how separate truth from lie and then ask
how and he said
just never lie and when you are never
lying
the lies become some you know uh
different energy and you can you can
sense it
and i think that's what's happening with
mai she has
really really great understanding
what is right and what is wrong and
she's very
passionate about you know saving planet
helping animals recently she turned to
veganism and i
i didn't push her to do that in any way
and either opposite i try to ask her if
she's sure
you know if she feels that if she feels
it's right
and she made this decision you know when
she tried to
eat vegan food right now yeah because
she's really care about environment
and yeah i think i want to share um this
her recent answer on the one of the
questions
and we really sometimes just
i i'm not seeing her
as you know little kid who don't know
anything
like i see absolutely opposite i'm
learning from her
i'm constantly asking what she feels
about things
there was this very interesting
situation when
um we was i think it was in the beverly
hills or
yeah i think it was in the beverly hills
she has a really great sense of
just space around her and
um we we was doing some things and she
got really hungry
and we didn't have a car at the moment
and i was just
trying to find in the google the closest
place to eat the closest restaurant
or cafe and we walked to this
and there was a beautiful place like you
see there's i don't know like roses
furniture
everything is beautiful great expensive
restaurant
and we sit there and she's like
mom i don't feel i i don't want to eat
here
you know like how conscious is this for
a kid
i think she was seven or eight years old
at the moment who is actually hungry
to say i don't really feel about the
space i don't really like the energy of
this place we should leave
and i said sure maya okay if you if you
can't wait
i'll pick another place and we can go to
different place and we're leaving the
place
and the fight starts there's a fight
there
there is yeah there is a guy there is a
guy who's
who started fighting yeah and
you know wow as you were leaving there
you go
wow and i totally trust her
you know i really i really do and
i constantly tell her about how talented
she
is you know and and i try
to never judge her and it's very
opposite of from
how i was raised you know in this
traditional schooling system and
yeah she will come up with some
incredible wisdom which i just share
with you and i think i want to share
with everyone
and in one of the conversations she was
asking me
about god and she is like oh okay so how
everything is here how everything is
worked and i
catch myself on
you know trying to explain something
from a buddhist philosophical books
about
how the nature of consciousness and then
i was like whoa
it stopped i should let
her not take in my
my thing but been able to think herself
and i just tried to give her the
question
in the way of the kind of game you know
and just like imagination game and i
said you know
what if you would be the creator
how you would create the world yeah
and she was thinking for a second
and tells that you know i would create
light from the love i have
to this world i would put it to my heart
and make it shine in all the direction
and every piece of this light
would become a soul independent soul
but always stay connected with me
even they have this long traveling
to somewhere you know
that's what she said at age
yeah it was recently that's what's up
that's what's up
[Laughter]
stories of enlightened children
i love it this is the this is the
natural state
i would say of
children is what you're describing and
that the economic machinery and
non-enlightened parents usually beat the
[ __ ] out of
these states of play curiosity
enlightenment out of children the
economic machinery
parents stressing and struggling in that
big
soup monopoly board
so it requires
parenting where
as maria montessori says you follow the
child
and in this case you really just let the
child
be themselves and you catalyze the
child's interests
mom skateboards look really interesting
no idea what that is
let's play with it let's see what
happens okay let's do it
it happens again with
the trust of you're right at a level of
awareness when
child's yeah seven eight years old to be
able to say something like
and they're hungry which they want the
one marshmallow they want the one
gratification marshmallow but
to be so tapped into an awareness of an
environment
that maybe even you weren't registering
so much what they were and to surrender
yourself to the wisdom
of a seven or eight year old is
something that a lot of parents don't
have the
humility to do and so
to agree to leave and to see the child
make a decision for
two marshmallows because there's
probably something that might be
happening that's not
that's being sensed that then
you see the fight breakout as you leave
and
a parent must catalyze states of
awakening in their child
it's mandatory you have no other option
but to do this
because if you don't do this you are
going to create a significant amount of
unneeded suffering
and trauma in their life in your life
because
you chose to do things that were
pressing them in directions that you
stopped you stopped your familial
process of doing that to you
and what you're doing in science has
validated this through epigenetics
is you're stopping your familial
traumatic
pathologies and you're now passing along
to maya
a new fresh set of
non-pathological methylation
and other epigenetics that then enable
her to actualize her gifts
in unique ways that
you weren't a that you weren't
completely able to and especially your
parents and their parents and their
parents weren't able to and
who how was she gonna be as a mother
there you go that that's kind of the
insight that
we wanna walk down as more enlightened
parents you had the opportunity in this
process of inquiry of what
god is to be able to say something that
came from
what you had previously learned right
here's
my concepts and my schemas and i'm gonna
put them into you because i'm right
and to choose to
be a higher level in a sense
teacher like your teachers do to you
like you do to
your child where you provide an
inquisitive question for them
to follow down a path of their own
inquiry their
own unique ways of expressing
that beautiful thing that maya said
i don't know other seven eight-year-olds
that know how to say things
like they're
that that loving light radiating in
every direction from the heart that then
every single soul is its own unique
individual but is connected to that
point that's a gorgeous
understanding and and i don't think
about this how many adults say something
like that
there you go there you go that should be
enough
for people to realize that if you don't
even have a social fabric of adults that
say things as wise as that
then how does all of a sudden an
eight-year-old produce
thoughts like that well maybe
we should follow some more of these
principles
that we're discussing and maybe we can
have a more enlightened
children and adults that are
architecting a future that's more
inclusive that's more bright that
flowers everyone's unique gifts
that takes solid care of our planet and
solid care of each other along the
journey that gets us to
the beautiful star trek future of
abundance that we all want to prosper in
so these are the
star trek architects in my opinion very
clearly
extremely clearly i don't even need a
second
thought of saying questioning that not
at all
this is this is the generation
alpha that i believe
that's born from 2010 to 2025 i believe
that kids
like maya are the very very clear
leaders the ones that are most
incapacity given their lineage given the
wisdoms of their parents given things
like this
that enable them to be those
architects of that star trek future that
enable them to
channel the most divine the highest
through them so we'll see i mean it
this is something interesting that i
mentioned to you before we started
it could be a lot of fun to have maya on
the show could be a lot of fun
maybe it's something that we can vibe on
and see what happens
i love stuff like that it's super fun
it will be fun for sure yeah what
podcasts
sit down with at the time maybe she'll
be nine
possibly by that time but uh what
podcasts get to sit down with
nine-year-olds that have more
awakened states of being and
share that with the world and like what
would that do to a 40 year old
even a 30 year old adult that is sitting
there in some constrained
being watching a nine-year-old so
blissfully expressing themselves
that's the kind of stuff that could make
maybe
be like why am i so constrained and why
am i so
not like that where did my ability to be
like that go and then
that's when maybe maybe children
maybe these sort of light architects
that we're talking about maybe they're
the ones that can penetrate the hearts
of the adult
level consciousness
um so again it's you know
takes takes just one question
when you try to make your kid do
something
or be certain way just ask yourself at
this moment
like why am i thinking it's right
where is it come from you know as we was
talking that
few questions will bring you to
compassion
sometimes this simple question
will bring you to the habit and just
to the habit which you used to
experience in your childhood
and which just repeating unconsciously
and you don't ask yourself you just
following because it's right like why
why is it right you know
and i find here the meditation as the
the greatest tool for that so you're
starting to be able to notice in
this patterns and for me it was
uh my mom she's very
she's extremely um
she thinks about herself her picture of
herself is a very reliable person
and the worst thing for her if she's not
if someone's expectations is not
approved you know from her side so
she was all my childhood she she always
tried to be on time
everywhere and she would start to make
me bean and hurry
like we need to go somewhere in an hour
let's say an hour before or two hours
before she would like
we're getting late we're getting late
we're getting late and it made me
feel so much panic and i just freezed my
reaction was freezed
i i first started to panicking and try
to you know get my things together
to be able to to live
and i just was i had so much anxiety
anxiety i just couldn't do anything and
i just freezed
and i found myself at the certain point
do the same thing to maya not that
yeah not in this extreme way but
something like hey maya come on come on
yeah and then i was like wait i you know
i kind of keep
sensing this similar you know
it's even it comes in a different words
sometimes but energy is similar
yes and i just started to stop myself
and i feel that i'm teaching now
kids meditation and that's my biggest
passion right now about teaching
mindfulness kids and to show them
this gap between stress and reaction and
then
that you usually can choose
and that's such a simple tools you know
it's it's over here
just just start asking yourself
start meditating and just noticing
what's happening within you around you
yeah that's so simple and that's so
life-changing
the pause between
the stimulus and the
stimulus right
and the reaction
is where
so much of our power is reclaimed
and
the same way that we were mentioning
that
after three seconds of focus
that the monkey mind races off and
ruminates for a minute
in some thought is actually
very applicable to this
pause to this time between
the stimulus and the response
all of our power is reclaimed there and
the more that you train
your ability to do something like be
able to
focus on your respiration for an
extended period of time
or focus on that meditative or
mindfulness practice for an extended
period of time
the more that you train yourself and
re-baseline yourself to be able to have
a longer
pause between the stimulus and the
response
and when that happens then you are
sovereign
and that's where you type into your
intuition let's do it yeah let's um
let's let's unpack this
let's jump into the intuition so what do
you mean by that
intuition is seeing
the right timing for right move
i think which is very difficult
now and nowadays
where there is so many you know social
media
and just labels about what are you
supposed to do
how you supposed to do that and you just
reacting on the stimulus
without actually consciously choosing on
which stimulus i truly should react
and for me the intuition where you go
through this
white noise and you truly feel because
you know we're here still for a reason
in this physical bodies and you have to
accomplish something
you have to do some right moves but
otherwise
by reacting on each stimulus you just
create new karma
you know and it's just like a big
snowball it's getting bigger bigger
bigger and bigger
and you're stressed out you don't have
time
you
yeah that's why i told you for me is
intuition goes with meditation
it it goes together and during my
lifetime i would
experience uh sometimes
this moments of intuition and
intuition intuitive insight
which i explained after
or opposite i would have insight during
the practices during
going on the retreats you know and like
clean
clearing out clearing out all this noise
you know and [ __ ]
and deeper and deeper and deeper and you
see that's what i
that's how we um that's how our
communication tonight starts with
brandon
right and uh the master of sound
that's how i will remember him the
master of sound
and uh remember we were talking about
that
everyone can share this
truth of nature of consciousness through
their gifts through
creativity and for me i had this
deeper experience where i can bring this
deeper state of mind through my voice
through through singing through
talking you know and i feel like when
you become connected
with yourself during this white noise
you find your intuition and your
authentic
way to express yourself and to bring
this truth to this world which transform
transforms you and people around you
and you'll never you never be confused
about that you know you're never
confused about that
like you literally start to feel how
this uh
habits and patterns which are
you know sometimes feel so
solid as it was with my with my
stepfather
you know i hate him that's it that's
very solid
concept but here is like
it's melting through this you know
through this power of love and you can
express it maybe you can draw maybe you
can sing maybe you can move
maybe you can guide a podcast and ask
people in the way you ask and bring it
you know
like right here
the right action at the right time
i like this example which actually my
rinpoche gives
and he said about this loving presence
and
you know it's also i believe that this
is a skill as much as you go to the
space and
as you bring your talent as you feel
this truth as this nature of
consciousness
as more you become it's more familiar
it's become the translation of the word
meditation is make something familiar
you make this familiar
right and like and you and you start to
share it with the world
and for people like myron poche
who is who live in the state of mind who
live
in the nature of mind which is love and
compassion who is
always there and it doesn't matter what
externally happened
and uh he had this metaphor of
when you are next to the people like
that and you are able to
to touch their loving conscious
it's your mind and what is the
difference between your mind and buddha
mind
your mind is like a piece of cube of ice
and the buddha mind is a water and when
you are connect
with loving compassionate people
it's the same like as they breathing
warm air to this eyes you know and you
kind of have this sense of life
how it can be and it can clean out some
karma
you know
i like that analogy a lot strong one
a lot of us feel that analogy
with as we become better at
that pause between the stimulus and the
response
when we gain that power we gain that
sovereignty we gain that intuitive
capacity that you speak of that right
action at that right time
everything slows down everything slows
down
we become ninjas
we become jedis while
we can very
clearly see the
essence of what it's like
to not have that pause
in others
and our ability
to breathe the
loving compassionate warm air
onto the ice of
those in the circumstances is that
butterfly effect of that god
consciousness
it's just it's only it's only so much
that
that we can do to share these types of
brilliant
stories and experiences and profound
perennial spiritual mystic traditions
people must
actually take initiative themselves to
explore the truth of this and
i i wish for more
people to be able to explore this
because
i know that that will solve the vast
majority of our ethical and moral
dilemmas on the planet it will
ensure that the sustainable development
goals get architected
very well and it will make sure that
the young ones like maya and the ones
beyond her
have a super
epic massive abundant star trek
playground for them to be able to
express their creative gifts
in so i want to pass
that on to the seventh generation
i don't want to pass along the
pathologies that we have today
and honestly you don't even have to help
them just like
just let them be who they are you know
just be that warm air that is breathed
everywhere you go
and you will just naturally melt ice
cubes
with your love compassion
bliss joy peace
i like how rupert spyra says
imperturbable peace and causeless joy
i want to ask a question about intuition
a lot of this resonates with what
lao tzu was teaching as well about wu
wei
the idea of effortless action
and so the more that you tap into that
dow that god
that intuition that right action at the
right time it becomes an effortless
process
my feeling around that is that that is
an absolute beautiful truth
and at the same time i have sort of a
an interesting way of perceiving how
other people have behaved in a way that
they claim that they're following an
intuition
but the intuition makes absolutely no
logical sense
zero
and i'm not i'm not saying that i don't
even want to separate logic and
intuition i don't even want to separate
the concepts i want to keep
everything as one whole
but it's very clear to me that there are
circumstances where people will behave
in a very
kairos fashion
where there will be some sort of an
intuitive
lightning bolt of sorts that says that
maybe i should go and
i'll give you an example of maybe i
should drive my
car 10 hours to some
location where i think there is a person
that is having some sort of a event
that i should attend but this person is
holding it very exclusively i don't even
know the location of the event
i'm only going to show up there five
hours after the event has actually ended
in the middle of the morning
and so i'm still gonna go because
intuition's telling me to
how do you respond to something like
that
i think that's what we was talking about
the middle path
you know there is definitely a middle
path
and you are not going to this extreme
type of
type of things even from you know my
stories it was like
i guess it's pretty extreme to hear
these things
i'm not saying that everyone i have to
do these things but you know just
it comes to simply to meditation
and stillness at least 15 minutes
per day and just to
calming your mind not trusting
your thoughts and trying to find
some space between the tendency of your
mind to cling
to things let me explain to you
on in the way of i'm learning now
handstand right yeah how to do a
handstand yeah you're really
are you doing it against the wall right
now yes yes yes sure i'm doing it yeah
that's that's the i've i can only do it
against the wall i can't
yes but it's really kind of
decompressing for the back and
it's kind of nice at times it's so the
thing is
while i'm doing it i i've noticed
that my mind tried to find
familiar feelings in my body
how to do that but i never did it before
that's right
that will be a new feeling no you're
training the muscle
yeah intuition is so rare
you know it's like uh beyond
the things you know it's beyond the
things you know there is this beautiful
uh application which i will share with
you i totally forgot the name of the guy
um who had this amazing ted talk
who was working in uh fbi for
years and he talks about the psychic
abilities
and how to go to this intuitive space
and he has this application where
basically
four um how do you call this
uh shape
to score where yes so there is a four
squares and
under one of this square there will be a
picture
and you have to feel intuitively where
the picture is
that's so simple and that's so
interesting i think you have like 28
tries
and also you know like you starting to
do these things
and you're like oh i feel that i get it
and the moment when you think that you
feel that you get it you losing it
you know and it's about intuition i
think that
sure it can appear in the certain
moments
of life and from my experience
you will never confuse it
you will never confuse this truth with
something else
but at the same time to consciously
develop
intuition i think it takes time
and effort you can't if you're not
able to as you said focus for a minute
and not let your mind run to the random
thoughts
i'm not sure that you being able to be
truly connected with your intuition and
to
hear what is intuition you know and
separated from the [ __ ] in your
monkey monkey mind interesting yeah
i don't know if it was a response spot
on so
as though one's ability to
become
sovereign with their consciousness to
the degree at which
they are able to focus and they are not
in rumination of monkey mind
that that enables them to hone in
on intuition more effectively
so that's the pairing of the intuition
in the meditation on a more close level
and then
i liked your immediate response of
middle path
i think that's fair i
feel like that's definitely been
extremely true for me especially given
chapter 7 the sorting algorithm where
you drain the dirty bath water and you
take the baby and you merge them
together that is middle path
so seems like it's a good
way for people to
be is where they see that very more
clearly to where there's
where where that does become something
that is very central
and at the same time that the more that
they work on that
muscle of the intuition where they work
on the muscle of meditation
and intuition the more that everything
aligns
everything just aligns i'm following
totally following and you say it's
you know 5 10 15 minutes a day
and my my at least my
my my recommendation is to
there's so many different combinations
of like we said there's so many
different
items on the buffet to try and pick from
and merge and you got to go all the way
to water and
all of this type of stuff
but there's nothing right now that is as
profound in my opinion
as the advaita vedanta direct path
i had so many so many jokes about that
culture girl remember one i'll give you
i'll give you one but just explanation
of
uh so in tibetan buddhism we call it
like crazy wisdom
you know when you do
all kinds of stuff you know
man i try to translate it
from russian there is a one of my friend
who tried to avoid
um argument in a chat
in a facebook by saying like uh
by creating from the word advaita make
it
um how to say like transform it it
sounds in russian like transform it like
by like advicing everyone in this chat
like you know i'm advising everyone in
this
in this chat yeah but
yes yes yes
there are definitely
aspects to other perennial spiritual
mystic traditions that are also similar
to the direct path of advaita vedanta
and even there are tastes
of what we are describing in the
greek philosophical traditions and in
many other
just planetary wisdoms where there is
basically a
that same teacher that we were
describing earlier that is
constantly anchored in the warm breath
that there is a transmission that's
happening from that
warm breath and that transmission
is in the form of not only that loving
compassionate presence
but the warm breath is also transmitted
through
question that enables
the conscious agent
to inquire
into the nature of their awareness and
reality
and that is in essence the direct path
because as soon as that conscious agent
begins flipping
the direction
of their arrow from everything being
external outward outward outward and
they do the oroboros where it goes
inward onto the subject investigating
itself
which we've absolutely atrophied that
muscle
in modernity that
that process catalyzed by these
styles of perennial spiritual philosophy
warm breath
direct path
it's exactly the the trigger that's
needed in the modern society we live in
they're not going to go on a 10-day
meditation retreat
they're want to look at instagram and
tick tock
this is the world the economic machinery
make money
nine to five buy a purse do your thing
buy a new car impress a girl get married
have kids repeat repeat
[Laughter]
you know i love that you i love that you
uh brought it up and it's actually
i'm thinking that how
how far sometimes the modern world
is from this conscious space
you know even on the buddhist retreats
uh rinpoches and teachers because
you know the retreats you are usually
going through some stages
you first face with your complicated
emotions and this like very strong
uh duality of your own mind and then
uh usually in the end there is this
feeling of bleach
of love and even for the
people who are constantly go for these
retreats
you know still teachers would say all
the time
it's the nature of your own mind don't
you know like
and people will still like fall in love
you know after the
after the retreat in the way of like
hypo
or you know just like putting putting it
somewhere
yes and teachers would constantly say
like hey just meditate on this date
meditate on this day
this is you this is your this is not
someone you know around or
some how dalai lama said you know the
teacher is not
a piece of cake which you can bite from
you know
yeah there you go that's a great way to
put it that's a great way to put it
yeah and as leo tolstoy said the kingdom
of god is within you
the perennial spiritual traditions say
that exact
same thing so if we
inspire through our show through
the all the different memes that we
communicate
mimetics cultural information transfer
if we leverage our
abilities here in hollywood in the
mimetic
capital of the planet
to be able to shoot out
like within our idea space
these animated series
and memes that catalyze
that direct path style awakening
to millions of people
that is a really good way to butterfly
effect
the awakening i think there is like i um
i want to say
there's a actually like really pretty
simple steps
so you meditate you literally clear your
mind as you clear your room
uh you're in tune in with your intuition
you find your gift and share it with the
world
yep right yep
i like the
cleaning out the mind analogy to
cleaning the room
it's a really strong one
we
we typically think that it's not
that
much affecting us
having a a bit of a mess
around our living quarters
the more aware you become the more you
realize
that that little mess in the living
quarters of the mind
is exactly what inhibits the pause
it's exactly what inhibits the love and
compassion
and so it must be it must undergo the
process of a surgical
deep-rooted investigation and
eradication of suffering
increase the length of that pause
increase the amount of love and
compassion
it has to go under that process the
realization
of the conscious agent understanding the
nature of its own awareness
so
it must it must it must and i think that
we can spread memes most
effectively here in los angeles
i feel it i know it
it's in my heart
it's musical
there's already been so many powerful
episodes artistic
it's so artistic it is you know like
hitler could become an
artist you know there was this story
that he actually he wanted to become a
painter
and somebody like really hurt his
feelings
in a school and said that you will never
become an artist
so you know that could be such a
different scenario
you know the that that um
archduke franz ferdinand that was
assassinated that
catalyzed the
millions and millions of deaths of world
war one
15 or so million
that one sort of decision that
butterflied affected
and if that story about hillary becoming
an artist
and having that artist be just
just squelched
causes the massive
i believe the numbers approximately 75
million including civilians something
egregious the total number of world war
ii deaths
that
we're really beginning to play with fire
if one incident can lead to the
the death of millions of people
where consciousness rather than being
able to investigate itself
and express itself artistically
is pressure cooked into the economic
machinery
and ends up cascading some sort of
drastic malevolence
i also want to say that that's a serve
it serves us
and it's crazy to see that because it's
hard to see tens of millions of deaths
as something that serves us
it's crazy to even say that but it does
as in we're wiser we're wiser
but we're also playing with fire
so there's a lot more
epic subjects to discuss we
unpacked a lot that was that was a lot
of fun
it was a lot of fun there's so much oh
my goodness
oh my goodness yeah i totally lost the
sense of time i don't know what time it
is
i was just focused on god happening
right here
and i was just like this is perfect
everything's perfect
everything's like an expression of the
most beautiful artistic flowering
of creativity and it's just like yum yum
yum yum yum thank you
you you let it happen this way i was
i was worried a little bit because of my
uh
i still have this language barrier you
know and i just
i moved here three years ago and i just
learned
american english and there are sometimes
it's getting difficult for me to explain
such a thing especially as consciousness
and with you it was so
easy you know because you create this
very safe space
and you really embody what you talk
about
and in your presence it's very
easy to you know to put
these things into words even i don't
have a huge vocabulary
so yeah thank you
that made me feel very warm very loved
very registered very appreciated
thank you thank you thank you it's
so nice to be able to feel that
be seen like that
you crushed it it was no language issue
whatsoever your
explanations of your journey and your
profound wisdoms
landed in my heart really deeply and
hopefully in other peoples as well i
think so
i think so
yeah what a cool story you have
remember when you first messaged it over
to me i was like
oh my god this is
so cool what an epic story well only
round one of
unpacking it is so much more
is it right there this is round one this
is what you said you know
yeah oh yeah there's round two round
three round four round infinity
how's this happening yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah this is what guests sign up for
is and that's why the
recommendation engine works the way it
does because
the experience of the guest is
one of which you describe which makes it
quite easy for the guests to be like
that was epic let's get other epic
people on here
and let's catalyze that awakening so
that's what kind of a container we aim
to make on the program and it absolutely
has to come from
an interviewer
that themselves is a
truly gnostic being they must have the
knowledge
anchored inside of them truly truly
and i'm still on my journey but i can
absolutely
tell that the spiritual fire within me
is so damn bright
it's so damn right and so that's what
enables the relationship to happen
between the other profound conscious
agent with their fire
with their flower essence smell
the aroma to fully be released
because i'm acting as a with my little
spray bottle
of loving water into flowers just like
and just blossoming so
you share so much with me i just sponge
it up i become more enriched in the
process the audience becomes more
enriched every guest does that process
to us
it's just this beautiful just beautiful
beautiful process i
just i really love what you said earlier
um
about you know i feel like you don't
really
sometimes need to have some extreme
experience
you know as you said oh this just
happened in the kitchen
yes i was just cooking food you know and
you can really
you can see the god in the eyes
of other person yes there is
just like you melt in this labels your
perceptions about how it's supposed to
be how this person is supposed to be
given this melting warm air
and here it is yes magic happen
you don't even have to go to ashram yeah
but sometimes you need to go
as well
the the sufi
mystics had their beautiful
saying everywhere you look
you see the face of god
i always recommend chapter eight
high level perception the magic trick
contemplate your source
contemplate your awareness the more you
do that
the more you realize the
oneness of all existence
everything coming from the same source
and when you do that
you begin thinking more holistically
and when you begin thinking
from the perspective of the whole
and then you simultaneously
channel that into your own artistic
individuation
that is
god consciousness that's all i have to
say
that's it i have another question for
you actually the silly ones
okay let's do it okay silly one is
do you shower in the morning or at night
both
you showered both times twice a day oh
you do
every day yeah interesting do you
yeah that's another it's a new response
it's a new response what can i say it's
a new response on the show we haven't
had that twice a day yet
i haven't had that yet how about
are you a five-minute 10-minute
20-minute 30-minute kind of shower
person how long are your showers
five minutes oh this is why you take two
showers
five minutes each boom boom yeah i see
it
you see boom boom yeah yeah
i'm wondering where is oh what is the
where's this investigation
yeah they investigate there's many
there's many points in this
investigation they're all very silly and
important i promise they're super
important points um
do you shampoo conditioner and body wash
soap do you use a loofah how do you no
no i don't use any of those
i mean i use shampoo and i use
conditioner and that's it
yes that's it okay
do you have shower thoughts what is that
shower thoughts is when you're in the
shower and you have some interesting
insights
in a shower you're five minutes in there
which is very fast
i don't know if you have much time for
your shower thoughts some people spend
like half an hour in there and
have a lot of insight yeah i think i do
sometimes
i think i do sometimes what are your
insights that you have in there
um mostly about the
upcoming day i'm thinking if it's uh
yeah it's either about upcoming day
about how to structure it
better i have ideas about uh how i have
to structure it
in a better way yeah and after
in the end of the day the thought is how
i could do it better next time
cool yeah okay
when you go to bed
you're at the end of the day if you are
wearing socks
how do you take your socks off
i actually uh take socks off right when
i
uh come in the house yeah and how do you
do it which
from here like wait
okay so you use your right hand i either
i
either use oh you know what yeah
i either use my right hand first or
either i do it with my legs don't use
hands so sometimes you just put your
foot on one sock and take it off and put
your foot on the other sock and take it
off yes
but sometimes you you go one hand and
then the other hand
okay do you flip them inside out or do
you keep them yeah i flew down
is it like uh was um uh the feedback for
a best questionary on these questions
of yours no they're just kind of like
silly questions not yet well maybe we'll
get some
sometime the audience will get to make a
decision and they'll be like
you know maybe add this silly question
take one out who knows
we'll maybe we'll rank these silly
questions
when you sleep do you sleep in pajamas
do you sleep in
i sleep naked me too yeah i sleep naked
too
yeah yeah
why do you sleep naked just feel more
comfortable
me too yeah yeah
yeah i feel more comfortable more divine
in the process i mean i would
just leave naked i would live naked me
too
me too me too that one deserves another
there's something weird about all of the
clothing
that's it's like an obsessive compulsive
disorder with fear of being naked
and so then that fear of being naked
just propagates
everything that we do and yeah so anyway
there's a lot of more spiritual
metaphysical
aspects to that but now
do you sleep approximately six eight
how many hours seven seven seven six
hours
more most of the time six six okay
do you lucid dream
you do do you
when you lucid dream do you normally
plan in some sort of a meditation prior
to bed kind of where you want to dream
what you want to do
that's what you do yeah okay i do that
and actually i had this ability from my
uh i didn't develop it i i or no it was
it will be uh wrong times
uh wrong thing to say so my grandfather
uh he used to tell me from the early
childhood that he can
order a dream and i think just this idea
which he put in my head that you can
order a dream and i would just do it all
the time
and i would fall asleep i was like okay
what i want to dream about
and sometime with work sometime it
didn't
but now i would
i would more being focus
on a falling asleep in the loving state
of mind
and again cleaning out all the
like garbage if i have some after the
day
you know and just like let universe feel
the details
you know just just stay in a open
compassionate state of mind but i
actually
i had few times and that was very
interesting because
um i have the experience before
taking a refuge buddhist refuge and
after and that was a really big
difference and i feel like the buddhist
refuge for me and for my subconscious
was the type of anchor and you know
all the buddhist practice is about uh
how to consciously die you know and
you're practicing and when you're
falling asleep because it's the same
similar thing right so you you learn how
to con how to control your mind
and after and uh like in a buddhist uh
tradition because of you put so much
trust and love
i'm trying to explain rationally if it
sound rationally
you put so much love to your teacher
at the moment when you losing yourself
in a dream
and you feel scared for example or there
is
some object which scares you the first
thing and
as well as when you die you remember
your teacher
yeah and when you remember your teacher
it brings your more energy more
confidence so you have to you are able
to control your mind
more you're not just running away from
the
fear yeah you know and i remember that i
had this
very vivid experience before
taking the refuge and after and there
was one
time when i was um in the lucid dream
and you know this feeling when you are
when you know that you are sleeping and
you are in your
like you know that this physical body is
right here in the bed
and there was this like really mean um
woman started to choke me
and the first thing i was like okay okay
what do i do what do i do i remember
rinpoche and i remembered my teacher and
then i was like
okay what else i remember i remember
that she is not something else but she
is my
my mind and i can actually make her
transform to whatever
and i make her transform into tara
this uh buddhist tibetan goddess
and then i was like whoa okay so what
next do i do
i'll create some other buddhas and you
know
just like amazing buddha hood
around me and i would just like start to
create
this and i remember this moment where i
was able to
create this reality very vividly yeah
and there was a moment where i was not
able
to let go and just to stay still
you know there was i could feel still
this tendency of
mind like not being able to totally
relax and trust
you know what i mean yeah that was that
was very interesting because it took me
to my
uh let's say like next step of my of my
practice
like i figured the tendency of my mind
through lucid dreaming
yep
yeah there's a great place for practice
in the dream world
for these types of
awakening
wisdoms
do you do a journal of your dreams
sometimes not all the time just based on
how
profound or interesting they are that's
what i do too yeah
what's your favorite food
um
seriously that's buckwheat for those
that don't know yeah that's a buckwheat
this honestly that the first thing come
to my mind i don't have a favorite food
oh you don't i don't have i don't have
favorite food i just uh my
mind just transform it into what if
there will be one product which
uh what if just one product would exist
which one you choose no i no
no no yeah it would be great i just mean
i don't have i don't have a favorite
food
yeah interesting
i like it a lot yeah it's been passed
down
so much in lineage so you kind of just
pick it up and get used to it yeah
i want to also briefly
check in about this in terms of
metaphysics just the nature of reality
kind of why it exists do you have an
idea
at why it exists why it exists
because it wants to play this game wants
to enjoy it
wants to express love
from experience i had not my thoughts
but experience
is just once to express love
and creates a different scenarios
making itself to believe
in suffering and pain
to being able to express love to
itself interesting
yeah that metaphysics is an interesting
one
it's one that we've played with
for the last couple of years in
different
sorts of
guests on the program have been sharing
things similar to that and it's been
really interesting
analyzing those because they resonate
they're fun
and then today
my
my intuitions around the
nature of reality seem to be mostly
around
consciousness exploring infinity
in it doing that eternally and that
this is just one exploration this is one
taste
you know this may be chocolate is the
four
limb 2i carbon based dna encoded
creature on this exact planet orbiting
the star
and that in order to get to
the tastes of vanilla strawberry mango
all these other tastes
that were about to enter into the
metaverse
which is where we came from which is
that
synthesis of artificial general
intelligence and simulation theory and
bio and neurotech
mixed realities infinite designer
realities that
we go into and then we pop out
exploring another 80-year experience
of some sort of a conscious agent
experience that
enables consciousness to just continue
exploring infinity because you can never
finish exploring something that's
unbounded
so if that's more
of something that can be investigated
mathematically by
us it's exciting
because i like the stories of play and
fun and exploration and
playing with the illusion of separation
and all of these things they're very fun
i'm also simultaneously looking at a
something that is exciting to play with
mathematically
so if it's possible
it could be exciting you know this story
about
um i think it was brahma vishnu and
shiva
this hindu story when they was talking
about who is a who's cooler
you know and they uh
try to find the way
uh what was they doing they were like
trying to find the limits of universe
and the shiva
like would go in in a
infinite space you know like to the to
the olive direction and they couldn't
find the
beginning and the end there you go
[Laughter]
man conscious agents must
expand their awareness to
these truly infinite
eternal cyclic
god-like states of being
our brahman that's right
that's right baby existence
consciousness bliss i love it
amen i and my father are one john 10 30.
todd von mossy you are that we are that
al-wujud the unity of all being
existence from the sufis
diversity and oneness is the mathematics
of the infinite tree orbindo the mother
mural fossa
all right that's it boom
good stuff that's it that's a wrap i'm
proud of us
that was awesome
one more i love it
i love it that was super awesome thank
you
yeah there's many more to come we're
only scratching the surface
we're only scratching the surface let us
know let us know your thoughts in the
comments below also if you want to see
maya on the program
oh yeah we'd love it we'd love to we'd
love to get some
nine nine-year-old awakened
consciousness to enter in the hearts of
the 30 year olds that are watching so
they can
realize what the infinite joy bliss
looks like
oh man hopefully we can do it we'll
explore
we'll explore we'll see check out the
links in the bio below everyone
thanks for tuning in massively
appreciate you
you have uh you have lyanna's insight
app
teacher profile so she's got a bunch of
online courses on there and you can find
it
on the links in the bio below but it's
on the web or on the
the insight timer app as well check that
out
also she has a bunch of other projects
that
she's currently on her instagram page
you can go find those there she's got
mindful mom she's trying to promulgate
mindfulness in secular ways around the
planet
she's got a human cosmos app super
interesting stuff
pure zen su is the most recent project
short simple tools to bring awareness to
the present moment with love and
compassion
so a lot of epic stuff to check out
definitely follow her
for more on that
yeah that's uh that's the essence
go and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world support the
artists the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders the scientists engineers those
that are building the future you can
support us
all of simulations links are in the bio
below support us help us flourish
and that's it investigate your
consciousness listen your thoughts on
the bio below
keep in touch about these deeper states
of meditation and intuition keep us
posted
big love good job it was so fun
that was so fun much love see you soon
peace guys